beaucoup d'être avec nous chargé des
relations avec le parlement et de la
participation citoyenne on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par julien lécuyer
de la voix du nord bonjour julien
bonjour rien le ministe mon jour on
commence bien sûr marc chesneau avec
vous par la disparition d'une figure de
la politique d'une figure du centre
marielle de sarnez figure historique de
votre parti le modem qu'elle avait fondé
avec françois bayrou
quel est votre sentiment ce matin d'un
créneau mais c'est à la fois une grande
tristesse
et puis il ya quelque chose d'irréel à
sa disparition
mariée elle a accompagné toutes les
aventures toutes les difficultés tous
les combats du centre au fond nous
avions fini par voilà par la pensée
invincible tant elle avait elle avait
surmonté des difficultés d'ordre
politique et donc il ya quelque chose ce
matin de totalement irréel à sa
disparition nous la savions malade mais
nous nous avions pensé et j'avais pensé
qu'elle vaincre est aussi cette maladie
puisqu'elle est décédé d'une leucémie
donc c'est un grand sentiment de
tristesse était une femme très engagée
très libre très courageuse c'était une
parlementaire
reconnu par ses pairs comme présidente
de la commission des affaires étrangères
à l'assemblée nationale c'était une
grande professionnelle
j'ai appris beaucoup auprès d'elle et
beaucoup d'entre nous ont appris auprès
d'elle de ses deux de ses combats et je
tous les combats qu'elle a menée je
pense ce matin tous les combats qu'elle
a menée au fond pour cette famille de
pensée qui essayait qui cherchait son
espace par delà les clivages de la
droite et de la gauche
je pense aussi à son engagement européen
puis je pense à la femme qui était une
femme très pudique et au fond j'ai
toujours trouvé au rendez-vous quand les
uns ou les autres se trouvaient
confrontés à des difficultés
personnelles
il y avait une grande humanité chez elle
même si elle le elle pouvait le
dissimuler derrière une grande pudeur au
fond et donc c'est beaucoup de ces
beaucoup de tristesse pour tous ceux qui
ont travaillé pour elle
évidemment je pense à françois bayrou
avec qui il ya un long compagnonnage
politique c'est plus de trente années de
compagnonnage politique c'est une figure
du centre le centre lui doit beaucoup
l'indépendance du centre lui dois
beaucoup et leurs ebooks lui devons
beaucoup président macron d'ailleurs à
saluer à ce titre dans un communiqué le
fait qu'elle avait été l architecte
l'architecte de l'indépendance du centre
faisant témoigner où elle a été celle
qui a pensé qu'à un moment le centre ne
pouvait être lui-même que quand il se
débarrassait de la contingence d'une
alliance automatique
quelles que soient les moments de la vie
publique
elle apportait avec beaucoup de force en
essayant à chaque fois d'ouvrir des
espaces était elle a une vision très
moderne de la politique est très
dynamique au fond et c'était très fort
et puis je pense vraiment à son
engagement aussi européen et
international elle a été toutes les
causes européenne elle était très
heureuse de voir notre engagement
européen aux fonds aboutir et de voir
des choses avancer au niveau européen
puis des grandes causes internationales
y compris humanitaire sur lesquels il
était très dur et je crois qu'elle est
et il était très engagé je crois qu'elle
est je crois je sais qu'elle était très
respecté de ses pairs quel que soit
d'ailleurs il beaucoup d'hommages hier
soir tous ceux qui ont bien travaillé
avec elle avec une forme d'exigences qui
était très utile dans la vie politique
nous avait dit en ce qu'elle a apporté à
votre famille centriste vous
personnellement quels souvenirs vous en
gardez de marianne elle garde le
souvenir la première fois que j'ai vu je
crois que c'était à blois
elle accompagnait françois bayrou et
puis après j'ai gravi les échelons avec
son regard et la volonté qu'elle avait
de faire naître de nouveaux de nouveaux
talents et puis moi je me rappelle de la
des campagnes présidentielles de 2002 de
2007 celle de 2012 et puis celle de 2017
où elle avait été elle aussi
l'architecte du dépassement au travers
de la candidature d'emmanuel de macron
je me souviens de deux longues soirées
où nous préparions parfois les élections
législatives
on nous faisions des analyses pour
essayer de regarder comment cet espace
pouvait vivre et puis des moments
parfois de conseil sur telle ou telle
situation quand il y avait eu des
moments d'échec elle a toujours été
présente à mes côtés m'a fait confiance
avec françois bayrou au moment où il
m'avait désigné secrétaire général du
mouvement démocrate
voilà c'est j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses et je lui dois moi
personnellement beaucoup en terme
d'apprentissage et de ce que je suis
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de ce que m'a
apporté marielle de sarnez
on reviendra bien sûr sur sa disparition
dans cette émission dans le club des
territoires dont l'actualité
marc fesneau il ya bien sûr cette crise
sanitaire et jean castex qui prendra la
parole à nouveau ce soir à 18 heures
pour faire un point sur l'épidémie est
peut-être annoncé de nouvelles mesures
est-ce qu'on va vers une nationalisation
du couvre-feu ou est-ce qu'on va rester
sur des mesures territorialisées vous me
permettrez de laisser jean castex
déployer les choses simplement vous dire
qu'on est confronté à une épidémie avec
laquelle il faut être prudent avec un
certain nombre de mesures qui ont été
prises dans la deuxième vague à partir
de l'automne couvre feu puis confinement
et puis les confinements et des mesures
quand même de précaution y compris de
couvre feu qui ont été reprises dans les
territoires dans lequel l'épidémie
semblait refluer les refoulant b nous
avons la question des variants en
particulier britanniques - pour
l'afrique du sud mais il faut quand même
regarder ce qui s'y passe est donc un
certain nombre de mesures françois
delfraissy alerte qui presque à ce stade
plus inquiétant que le virus anglais le
virus anglais
et mieux connue désormais pour peu qu'on
puisse parler de connaissance quand on
sait que c'est un variable est apparue
il ya moins de trois semaines
autant que je me souviennes donc le
premier ministre ait eu un conseil de
défense et beaucoup de dialogue et de
discussion annoncera ce qui l'a annoncé
ce soir les dissidents sera annoncée ce
soit donc je ne préempte aurait pas ce
qu'il va dire mais il ya une nécessité
de grande vigilance
on a une campagne vaccinale qui démarre
qui s'accélère comme vous avez pu le
constater et en même temps la campagne
vaccinale ne résout pas de compte tenu
du délai qu'il faut pour vacciner là
c'est l'ensemble de la population ou le
maximum de la population comme dans tous
les pays d'ailleurs il ya besoin de
maintenir les mesures de précaution il
ya des outils qui sont à notre
disposition et dont on parlera jean
castex ce soir monsieur est ce que on
l'a le la possibilité d'attendre pour
des mesures plus strictes j'entends que
au royaume uni il face à à la portée du
nouveau variant qui entraînait une
épidémie hors de contrôle
il a fallu reconfirmer en urgence la
situation sur en afrique du sud semble
montrer qu'il ya aussi une menace très
dangereuse au travers de ceux de ce
variant qu'est-ce qu'on peut encore
attendre avant de reprendre des
meilleures mesures plus strictes mais
nous n'attendons pas nous avons toujours
été réactif on nous avait d'ailleurs
reproché un peu au mois deux à l'automne
de prendre des mesures à l'époque en
nous disant qu'on était en avance de
phase et qu'on ne comprenait pas
pourquoi à ce moment là il fallait
prendre des mesures en particulier des
mesures de couvre-feu au démarrage
je pense que nous sommes réactifs et
nous essayons d'ajuster les dispositifs
à la réalité de la pandémie
ce qu'on sait du variant anglais c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il est plutôt présent
dans un cas sur cent détecté en france
détectée c'est important de le dire
puisque l'aller le séquençage kiki même
à la découverte du
du variant n'est pas au point à l'heure
actuelle il n'est pas opérationnel
complètement sinon mais sur la porte
quand je dis 1 % c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est proche d'une
réalité puisque c'est sur les jeudi
vendredi samedi dernier il a été fait
sur tous les tests positifs une enquête
flash c'est à dire sur plus de avec
15000 à 20000 qu'à part par jour on est
sur une enquête sur soixante mille cas
quand vous êtes un pur sang vous
commencez à avoir quelque chose qui
statistiquement nous paraît me paraît
raisonnable mais évidemment nous sommes
vigilants et évidemment tout tout notre
logique est la logique de l'action du
gouvernement est une logique qui
permettent en avance de phase d'
imaginer ce que peut être cette épidémie
d'imaginer sa dynamique au mauvais sens
du terme et l'imaginer les mesures qu'il
faut prendre pour ralentir cette
épidémie je crois que c'est le
professeur delfraissy requis a dit le
variant anglais il est présente
désormais partout sur le territoire
européen c'est une chose en même temps
le seul sujet c'est d'arriver à ralentir
ce variant anglais et puis globalement
de ralentir cette phase épidémique
puisque nous savons que à la fois la
saison la climatologie joue beaucoup et
que donc à partir d'un certain seuil on
peut avoir des phénomènes exponentielle
ce qu'on a vu en grande bretagne en
grande bretagne c'est à la fois un sujet
de l'épidémie telles qu'elles étaient
plus le variant anglais qui vient
rajouter un certain nombre de choses ces
deux choses qui vient depuis dénudant
l'épidémie l'épidémie dans l'épidémie
par ailleurs les anglais avaient fait un
choix qui était assez différent depuis
le début d'épidémie avec des mesures de
confinement ou des mesures de couvre feu
qui avait été beaucoup plus légères que
les nôtres et au fond l'épidémie est
devenu exponentiel accompagné du variant
angles mais mes skis a pas d'autres
mesures quand même à prendre alors au
delà dont on a parlé des mesures de
couvre-feu ou de ou de confinement mais
il semble que la situation par exemple
dans les universités soit vraiment très
compliqué
le professeur delfraissy a noté la les
problèmes psychologiques qui sont créés
chez les étudiants est ce qu'il n'est
pas temps de prendre des mesures là
aussi de ce côté il ya deux choses dans
la question que vous posez la première
c'est évidemment les universités ont été
des lieux particulièrement il y avait
une vigilance en termes de contamination
est donc la responsabilité qui est la
nôtre c'est à la fois de ne pas laisser
les étudiants dans l'absence totale de
contact avec leurs universités en même
temps de les protéger et de protéger
l'ensemble de la population de la
propagation du virus
et puis de il ya une attention
particulière apportée sur eux du fait de
ce que vous décrivez qui est très juste
et le détresse psychologique concentre
un isolement en isolement à sa famille
en isolement à ses collègues de
l'université une précarité parfois
financière une précarité tout court qui
vient s'ajouter à la précarité
psychologique est donc le premier
ministre le président de la république
l'a rappelé hier en conseil des ministre
annoncera à saint-hernin de choses et
puis quelque chose de l'ordre d'actions
en faveur de ces publics là restera la
question il reste la question de quel
mal il y aura d un certain nombre de
choses qui seront sans doute annoncé
plus tôt à la fin du mois de janvier
parce que c'est un plan global sur
lequel nous essaierons de travailler
mais en tout cas le premier ni j'imagine
dressera des perspectives nous avons une
vigilance particulière parce qu'on sent
que c'est une une catégorie de la
population qui est particulièrement
touché particulièrement impacté par les
mesures être par exemple il faut à la
fois avoir des mesures de protection
sanitaire et en même temps des mesures
de protection de ceux qui par ces
mesures de protection sanitaire est très
lourdement impactés on verra les
dispositifs le poids ministre dira ce
qu'il a à dire est ce soir et dans les
jours qui viennent un mot encore sur le
vaccin puisque vous êtes aussi ministre
de la participation citoyenne
comment ça va se passer ce comité
citoyen qui a été mis en place sur le
hac 5 ans vont démarrer les travaux
qu'elle va être le calendrier les
travaux vont démarrer là c'est sous
l'autorité du sérieux je pense qu'il
faut la séquence dès samedi où je crois
que c'est dès samedi
je crois qu'il faut lever les ambiguïtés
certains avaient pu peut-être de bonne
foi disons le peut-être pas de bonne foi
en tout cas dire que c'était ses
citoyens qu'elle est déterminée la
stratégie nex vaccinale il n'a jamais
été question de l'inquiétude des
parlementaires sur ce cognac il répondre
je crois que c'est pas du tout enfin je
crois je sais que là ce n'est pas du
tout la volonté du gouvernement la
volonté c'est d'avoir aux côtés des
parlementaires qui mène un rôle de vigie
permanente sur les territoires de ce que
la manière dont se déploie la seule
stratégie vaccinale d'avoir une
perception des citoyens de la manière
dont cette déploie mais la stratégie
elle est décidée déterminée par le
gouvernement c'est d'ailleurs sa
responsabilité par le dialogue avec le
parlement et puis par le dialogue avec
les autorités sanitaires et c'est bien
dans ce cadre là que les citoyens auront
en continu à dire ce qu'ils ont à dire
de ce qu'ils perçoivent de la stratégie
vaccinale de comment les citoyens à les
autres pas seulement cela perçoivent la
stratégie est ce que c'est pas le comité
de trop c'est ce qu'ont évidemment ce
qu'on nous laisse entendre ce que laisse
entendre la petite musique est assez
étonnant c'est que le président de la v
de la république l'avait annoncé dans
une allocution télévisée
et que certains ont semblé découvrir au
début du mois de janvier la mise en
place je ne crois pas du tout je pense
que c'est toujours utile d'avoir
plusieurs lieux où peuvent s'élaborer la
réflexion pour préparer une décision et
donc moi je pense que c'est un élément
utile c'est pas le seul c'est pas unique
c'est pas prédominant mais c'est utile
mais disons que ça venait à un moment
donné où l'actualité c'est un petit peu
télescoper avec la constitution du
conseil des citoyens dit avec les
accusations de lenteur vaccinale mais
d'ailleurs est ce que est ce que vous
reconnaissez malgré tout que au début de
l'année il y a eu certaines erreurs de
commises de la part du gouvernement
excès de timidité non lancement de la
campagne excès de timidité dans la
valorisation de l'acte de se faire
vacciner
non je ne crois pas je j'ai trouvé assez
étonnant comme en cent
symboliquement une première vaccination
je crois que c'était le 27 ou le 28
décembre que finalement dès le 29 ou le
30 on nous dise la stratégie vaccinale
ne fonctionne pas enfin je trouve que si
l'action publique se résume en 24 heures
à déterminer ce qui marche et ce qui ne
marche pas on fait défaut à ce qu'est la
continuité et le temps moyen et le temps
long de l'action publique la stratégie
vaccinale va se développer sur plusieurs
mois le premier ministre du ministre de
la santé olivier viron indiqué qu' il y
avait une première phase qui visait à
vacciner les publics les plus fragiles
sur lequel il y avait peut-être besoin
d'un accompagnement un peu plus fort que
sur d'autres publics en termes comment
dirais-je d'acceptation de la
vaccination sur les autres au public on
voit que probablement les choses seront
plus faciles et de l'objectif était et
reste et sera de vacciner un million
voire un peu plus d'un million de
personnes qui sont la cible pourquoi
c'est une cible parce que d'ici fin
janvier
et après le le mécanisme se déploiera à
la fin du semestre parce que là aussi le
curseur a bougé et on était sûr sur le
premier trimestre pour pour vacciner 15
millions personnes finalement on dit
jusqu'au premier au prg la fin du
premier semestre
est ce que concrètement vous êtes face à
ce que audi j'avais on dit appelle lui
même des zones d'incertitude il ya
plusieurs zones d'incertitude d'abord
l'autorisation de mise en marché d'un
certain nombre de vaccins zeneca par
exemple ils focalisent arriver qu'elle
se fasse deuxième élément il ya des
vaccins dont on pourrait penser que
c'était un horizon lointain puis dans
certains cas on nous dit que ça sera un
horizon plus proche est par ailleurs
faut quand même se dire les choses
personne
ah non il ya un an personne n'imaginait
même nos coronavirus au fond dans son sa
redoutable pandémie mondiale et personne
n'imaginait qu'on a en moins d'un an
on trouverait un ou des vaccins mais
après il faut les produire et donc c'est
pour ça qu'ils vont faire un ordre de
priorité comme tous les pays font des
ordres de priorité pourquoi on fait un
ordre de priorité je voulais je voulais
dire ça c'est parce que la population
qui est vaccinée en cible du mois de
janvier
c'est un pour cent de la population et
ses 30% des décès et donc c'est bien
dans cet ordre là qu'il faut faire les
choses parce que c'est dans ces tranches
la danse et public la con que le
l'épidémie fait le plus de ravages en
terme de mortalité est en terme
d'occupation des lits de réanimation sur
un mot sur le projet de loi qui va
prolonger l'état d'urgence sanitaire
inquiète actuellement en vigueur
jusqu'au 16 février cet état d'urgence
sanitaire est un projet de loi qui va
être examinée par le parlement la
semaine du 18 et la semaine du 25 mai
philippe bach le sénateur qui était sur
ce plateau hier il disait qu'il n'était
pas contre le prolongement de cet état
d'urgence puisqu'il comprend la
nécessité mais qu' il laissera pas un
blanc-seing au gouvernement jusqu'au 1er
juin est ce que vous êtes prêts à
revenir sur sa date du 1er juin pour qui
un nouveau débat au parlement d'ici là
où est ce que ça sera le 1er mai il ya
deux choses qui pue qu'ils puissent s'y
qui nécessitait débat au parlement
d'ailleurs le poème nice le milieu de la
santé n'ont jamais fait défaut débat au
parlement
on a toujours été à la disposition du
parlement au sénat comme à l'assemblée
nationale est en même temps sur des
dispositifs comme cela comme il s'agit
de prorogation est strictement dans le
cadre que ce qui est celui qui a été
voté à partir du mois de mars et à
plusieurs reprises reportée
il n'aurait pas échappé que nous avions
proposée s'étaient d'ailleurs la demande
des parlementaires d'inscrire dans le
dur si je peux dire de la loi les grands
principes de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
et qu'au fond un certain nombre de voix
se sont élevées pour dire il est trop
tôt ce n'est pas le moment où vous
feriez mieux de proroger désormais qu'on
prolonge on vient nous débattre de la
question du délai les parlementaires en
débattrons mais comprenez bien que dans
cette phase épidémique on a besoin
d'avoir un peu de stabilité
les dispositifs personne ne les découvre
ce débat il a déjà eu lieu à la fin de
l'année et déjà il a été contesté là
vous revenez finalement avec le même le
même combat et avec le même risque de
débats
mais avec le même dispositif parce que
c'est quelqu'un peut trouver des
dispositifs qu'ils soient plus efficaces
en termes je dirais juridique que je
veux dire ce que s'est stabilisé ça a
été validé par le conseil d'état puis
validée par le conseil constitutionnel
personne n'a trouvé à redire puisque les
textes ont été déférés parlement un
petit peu quand je parle d'un point de
vue juridique sur les outils juridiques
après on peut discuter de l'année on en
a parlé au tout début de l'effectivité
de telle ou telle mesure de l'activation
de telle ou telle religion mais d'un
point de vue juridique et philippe bas
qui connaissait question beaucoup mieux
que sam de coûts mieux que moi
et d'ailleurs le parlement et le sénat
et l'assemblée nationale en national ont
été fort utile pour pour oeuvrer dans ce
débat essayer de clarifier les choses
d'un point de vue juridique il n'y a
rien de nouveau d'un point de vue des
outils juridiques
c'est simplement une prorogation qui
permet tout simplement de pouvoir le cas
échéant être armé si vous me permettez
cette expression la face à ce que
pourrait être une remontée épidémique ou
pas et donc c'est bien de ça dont il est
question et le débat a lieu le débat
aura lieu j'imagine j'entends ce que ce
que dit philippe bas sur le sur le délai
mais il me semble qu'il faut donner un
peu de visibilité à tous de visibilité
aux citoyens de visibilité aux
parlementaires de visibilité au
gouvernement ça n'empêche pas le projet
de voter des lois en permanence pour
avoir des débats parlementaires et moi
je pense que c'est sain qu'on ait des
débats parlementaires je pense que c'est
un aiguillon qui est utile le prémunit
cela rappelez vous l'avez montré aux
questions gouvernement indien sait bien
qui est là qui est du débat qu'est la
discussion émission que sur disposition
c'est des choses qui sont calais après
viendra le moment où il faudra qu'on se
dise dans le cas d'une autre pandémie
on a bien vu au mois de mars 2020 à quel
point nous étions désarmés d'un point de
vue juridique pour faire face à une
urgence qui n'est pas une urgence
classique était une urgence de nature
sanitaire et ce alors pour le coup là ça
nécessitera des débats
entre parlementaires entre
parlementaires et gouvernement pour
stabiliser les choses et fasse des
données des éléments qu'ils soient des
éléments de visibilité mais je le dis
bien ce n'est pas anelka mais là on
verra mais il me semble qu'il faut que
c'est la responsabilité du gouvernement
c'est la responsabilité aussi me semble
t'il des parlementaires que de faire ça
en sorte que nous soyons outillés pour
faire face à des pandémies nouveau
projet de loi qui pourrait se cadrer
tout cela mais à un moment ou un autre
je répète c'était une demande des
parlementaires la demande des
parlementaires s'étaient on vous
autorise jusqu'au 1er avril pour un
certain nombre d'outils le cadre général
et à partir du 1er avril on vous
demandera d'avoir un texte qui
l'inscrivent dans le dur qu'elle ne se
soit pas une mesure d'exception qu'elle
puisse est activée et bien il y aura à
un moment ou un autre il me semble que
ce sera utile qui se débat je pense
qu'il faut la voir de manière
dépassionnée parce que c'est un outil
qui dépasse largement un quinquennat
cc des questions qui dépassent largement
la question de la majorité ou de
l'opposition c'est des questions qui
disent quand un pays doit faire face à
une pandémie que nous n'avions pas
connue depuis au fond presque une
centaine d'années avec la grippe
espagnole de cette nature la pandémie
mondiale et pontdémé à effets sanitaires
très puissant il faut qu'on soit mieux
doté nous avions oublié les ravages et
les difficultés auxquelles étaient
confrontés les sociétés face à des
pandémies de cette nature il ne reste
malheureusement peu de temps marc
fesneau monde va parler des autres et
forment un séminaire avait lieu hier
oui un séminaire gouvernemental pour
fixé les grandes priorités des mois à
venir des mois qu'ils sont enfin un
temps législatif qui va être extrêmement
court extrêmement dense
est ce qu'il y aura des des sacrifices à
faire parmi les grandes réformes que
vous portiez je pense évidemment à la
réforme des retraites à la grande loi
autonomie et dépendance qui était qui
était attendu est ce que vont faire les
frais de ce temps législatif
c'est pas une question de sacrifice lors
de ce séminaire le président la
république et pour ministre ont rappelé
la volonté de de poursuivre les réformes
malgré la pandémie de faire en sorte que
nous préparions le pays au fonds a pour
après la pandémie on nous reprocherait
si nous n'avions rien fait de ne pas
avoir avancé sur un certain nombre de
sujets dont il ya un certain nombre de
textes qui sont d'ailleurs
en navette je pense aux lois la loi qui
vise à lutter contre les formes de
séparatisme et un certain nombre de la
loi qui vise à à travailler sur et
conclusion de la convention citoyenne
sur le climat donc ça c'est des choses
qui sont qui sont déjà quand et si je
peux dire dans le calendrier
parlementaire après il faut une fois
faire des choix sur une question de
sacrifice ou faire des choix parce que
le calendrier parlementaire vous le
savez aussi bien que moi tous les deux
et forcément contraint et donc viendra
le moment où nous ferons des choix et
les choix doit se faire dans quels
horizons dans l'horizon 2 qu'est-ce qui
est aujourd'hui utile pour le pays et
qu'est-ce qui est aujourd'hui utile pour
les citoyens français et donc on sait
tous sur la question des retraites pour
essayer de vous répondre qu'il ya besoin
d'une réforme dure entre de retraite
mais évidemment le calendrier dépend
beaucoup aussi de ce que sera la
situation sanitaire il n'est pas
question pour nous de mettre le pays en
tension sur ces questions là mais
évidemment on aura un moment ou un autre
devant nous la question de ce fait nous
concrètement le président enfin
l'exécutif dit qu'on sortira certains
moments de la crise à la fin de l'été si
possible ça laisse ça ne laisse pas du
tout le temps de mener de toute façon
cette réforme
est-ce qu'il faut pas acte est tout
simplement le fait que c'est un très
beau sujet pour la prochaine fois elle
ne vous inquiétez pas du fait que nous
atteindrons un jour ou l'autre les
grands chantiers qui s'ouvre devant nous
à partir du moment où les grands
chantiers sur lesquels nous avons décidé
de continuer à avancer à partir du monde
près de nous sortir de la crise
sanitaire il ya des chantiers qui sont
déjà sur la table
nous continuons à transformer le pays il
ya eu 1 1 hier par amélie de montchalin
una présentation d'un outil qui est un
outil très utile je crois pour voir
l'état et la situation des réformes sur
les maisons françaises on lit le
baromètre sur la situation de tel ou tel
sujet écologie de tel ou tel sujet
économique de tel ou tel sujet social
lorsque ces fortes utile parce que je
pense que la vie publique a besoin aussi
d'évaluation c'est d'ailleurs une des
missions du parlement et je pense que
c'est un outil fort utile donc nous
poursuivons les réformes
et puis après comme vous le dites et
vous avez raison
le dire il y aura besoin de dire celles
qui pourront être faites et celles qui
devront bien parler par exemple la loi
autonomie la loi dépendance qui était
produit
j'ai dit hier - de l'année est ce que
cette loi elle va être inscrits l'objet
d'hier si vous permettez je n'ai pas
pour habitude de dire de toute façon ce
qui se dit dans des séminaires ou des
conseils des ministres
quelque chose auquel je tiens à ces
constamment donc je ne vais pas changer
d'avis ce matin n'était pas en tout cas
de rentrer dans le détail texte par
texte c'était plutôt d'avoir une
philosophie de l'action et de regarder
quelles étaient les grands chantiers
mais vous savez ce virus il nous a
appris quand même à tracer prudent et
donc quand vous gouvernez vous devez
regarder ce qu'il adviendra quand vous
sortez d'une crise mais quand vous êtes
encore dans la crise et nous sommes
encore dans la crise sanitaire vous
gérez aussi la crise sanitaire nous
avons un plan de relance a déployé c'est
une priorité urgente il justement un mot
là-dessus puisque bruno le maire a dit
que ça serait un défi d'atteindre 6 % de
croissance est ce que du coup il y aura
un budget rectificatif dans les
prochaines semaines je ne sais pas mais
il m'étonnerait qu'à un moment ou un
autre c'est pas une question budgétaire
qui viennent qui viennent s'adjoindre en
cours en cours d'exercice budgétaire
c'est bien normal puisqu'il faut une
fois dû ajuster nos dispositifs on voit
bien que les dispositifs de relance ont
été ajustés à un moment donné à un
moment tu es si je peux dire intenté et
qui aura sans doute besoin d'ajuster des
dispositifs leur faut quand même saluer
la capacité qu'a le gouvernement et la
capacité quel parlement et le sénat
compris d'ailleurs d'être très mobile et
d'être très agile et de pouvoir très
rapidement réajuster des dispositifs
quand tel ou tel secteur d'activité
nécessité des mesures d'accompagnement
garder il ya du temps l'on voit bien
qu'à des secteurs qui sont durablement
impacté par la crise quand bien même les
activités ont pu reprendre
je pense au secteur aéronautique très
puissant en france et qui est très
affecté par cette crise je pense au
secteur automobile en tome de transition
et de crise économique
on a besoin de les accompagner mais il y
aura sans doute besoin d'ajustements au
budget outre décentralisation julien ont
fait que oui on peut on peut le demander
la décentralisation et devait être
présenté en conseil des ministres en
janvier examinés au printemps au
parlement est ce que vous pouvez nous
assurer ce calendrier sera tenu
jacqueline gourault est en train de
poursuivre les concertations jour et
salué le travail est fait auprès des
collectivités locales ça fait partie des
textes qui ne sont des textes importants
et sur lesquelles il faudra des
arbitrages de calendrier est donc jacky
moreau ou moi même je reviendrai vous le
dire quand les choses seront arbitrés
quand interviendra ce cet arbitre les
arbitrages vont avoir lieu dans les
semaines qui viennent pas dans les
semaines qui viennent
ça veut dire non si l'on joue la fin du
mois sinon je vous aurais dit dans les
mois qui viennent oui donc si je vous
dis dans les semaines c'est plutôt dans
l'horizon du mois de janvier ou du mois
de février nous dirons ce que sont les
grands chantiers commencent à séquence
bombardons pardon ne pas vouloir être
plus précis d'abord je le dis parce que
c'est le fruit d'un dialogue avec le
parlement j'ai un dialogue gouvernement
un dialogue constant et parfois parfois
pas difficile mais parfois un peu tombé
avec un combatif avec le sénat mais je
veille au dialogue parce que je nous
avons besoin du sénat nous avons besoin
de l'assemblée nationale et vous me
permettez sur ces questions de
calendrier de priorités qu'on puisse
aussi en parler avec les intéressés au
sénat et à l'assemblée nationale vous
viendrez nous le dévoiler quand bien
volontiers mais très merci vous bien
volontiers si marc fesneau d'avoir été
notre invité merci julien regarder une
de la voix du zinc ou deux titres la
vaccination qu'on les plus de 75 ans et
puis c'est mr novice en temps de crise
c'est à lire aujourd'hui dans la voix du
nord n'ont pas de sou dit au club des
territoires la mutuelle
[Musique]